Prof: We've been going
through the generations of
organic chemistry,
from Lavoisier to Berzelius and
Gay-Lussac,
to Dumas, Liebig and Woehler,
and last time we got to Couper,
and began with Kekulé,
talking about their discovery,
or invention really,
of valence;
in particular the tetravalence
and the self-linking of carbon.
But the other thing that
Kekulé
is most noted for is the
structure of benzene,
and we started looking at that
a little bit last time with his
sausage diagrams for drawing a
structure.
And this time we'll go on in
more detail with that idea in
the determination of actual
position in molecules,
the positions of atoms in
molecules.
And this is largely due to
students of Kekulé,
so the next generation:
Wilhelm Koerner,
who was both in Germany and in
Italy,
as you'll see,
and Jacobus Henricus van't
Hoff,
from the Netherlands,
and also Albert Ladenburg,
from Germany,
and we'll even have a little
message of your own --
<<technical
adjustments>>.
Okay, so we -- Koerner,
van't Hoff, Ladenburg and
E.P. Kohler,
who is your
great-great-grandfather
academically.
Okay, so benzene and molecular
structure.
This is the simplest of the
so-called aromatic compounds.
Obviously the name comes from
the smell,
that it has an aroma,
but it was generalized from
benzene which --
benzene was discovered in 1825
by Faraday who isolated what he
called bicarburet of
hydrogen,
which was C_2H,
according to his formula,
but actually it's C_6H_6,
because he had the carbon
doubled and it's six times what
he thought it was.
And he got it from gas oil,
which is a byproduct.
Quite a bit,
you get a gallon -- or they did
at least then;
I don't know what happens
nowadays -- for making 1000
cubic feet of the oil,
that was an illuminating oil;
illuminating gas, pardon me.
So in 1833 Mitscherlich named
the compound benzine,
instead of bicarburet of
hydrogen.
And the origin of the name is
interesting.
It came from gum benzoin,
via benzoic acid.
So you knocked the CO_2,
somehow, off of benzoic acid,
and you get what Mitscherlich
called benzine.
Now gum benzoin itself has an
interesting etymology,
because it came originally from
luban jawi,
which I'm told is Arabic,
meaning frankincense --
that's luban -- and
jawi is from java.
So it came from the southeast
Asia.
But when the French saw this
name, they assumed that
lu was like le,
la, les,
and so on, the article.
So they knocked it off.
So it became ban jawi,
which doesn't mean anything in
Arabic, but that then became
benzoin and then benzine.
Okay?
The French, in 1841,
named the alcohol version
acide phénique,
because it's acidic,
and we'll see why shortly.
We call it phenol,
and we call C_6H_5 phenyl,
and abbreviate it Ph for
phenyl, or Î¦,
the Greek letter,
for phenyl.
And it comes from
phainein,
which means to bring light,
because of its association with
illuminating gas.
Okay, so we know that
Kekulé's structure for
benzene is hexagonal,
even though he wrote it with
that sausage thing originally.
Now why?
On what basis did he think it
was hexagonal?
Well this is the paper where he
proposed it's hexagonal,
and I'll show you all the
evidence he gave in his
arguments for its being a
hexagon.
First, "All aromatic
compounds"
(so,
for example,
benzaldehyde as well as benzene
and so on) "even the
simplest are significantly
richer in carbon than analogous
compounds from the class of
fatty substances."
Okay, so it's rich in carbon;
that's the first evidence that
it's a hexagon.
The second is that
"Aromatic compounds,
as for fatty compounds,
there are numerous homologous
substances;
that is, those who composition
differ by an integral number of
CH_2 groups."
So if you replace a hydrogen by
a methyl group,
you add CH_2,
right?
Or if you put a CH_2 into a C-C
bond, it becomes a little bit
longer, a homolog.
So there are homologous
substances in the aromatic
series.
The third line of evidence was,
"The simplest aromatic
compounds contain at least six
carbon atoms."
Okay?
And the fourth line of evidence
is,
"All reaction products
from aromatic substances show a
certain family similarity,
constituting the group of
'aromatic' compounds.
More vigorous reaction can
remove part of the carbon,
but the major product contains
at least six carbon atoms,
and decomposition stops at this
point,
unless there is complete
destruction of the organic
group."
For example, burning it.
And that's it.
Those are the four lines of
evidence.
So would you conclude from that
that benzene is a hexagon?
It's quite a stretch.
So was this just a wild guess,
based on the idea that carbon
should be tetravalent?
And even in a sense that
doesn't help much because
there's a question of what you
do with that last valence of
carbon, right?
So he did have some support for
this, but he didn't cite it in
the paper.
He didn't publish it until
later.
It had to do with counting
isomers.
So, remember this was the
formula he drew in 1865 of
chlorobenzene.
But in the next year,
when he started trying actually
to say that it was a hexagon,
he drew a hexagon -- he didn't
try to use his sausages at this
point --
and he contrasted it with what
you get with a triangle of
carbons,
with a carbon in the middle of
each edge.
Okay, so he labels the
vertices, the carbon atoms,
a, b, c, d,
e, f, and counts isomers.
And this is his table of that
count.
So monobromobenzene,
there's only one form.
Right?
Obviously if it were a chain of
six carbons, you could have it
on the end, or the carbon that
was next to the end,
or the carbon next to that.
Right? So there'd be isomers.
But, in fact,
only one was known,
monobromo.
Now how about dibromobenzene?
It turns out that there are
three modifications,
he says: ab,
ac, and ad.
How about ae?
ae would be next nearest
neighbors, like ac,
and af would be like
ab.
Okay, so three modifications.
That's consistent with its
being a hexagon.
Now how about tribromobenzene?
There are three;
drei modificationen.
Okay, abc.
So all successive, right?
Or skip one.
How about if you skip two?
How about abe;
should we have that one?
How about abe?
Kate, what do you say?
Should we count abe as
another one?
Steve, what do you say?
Student:  No.
Prof: Why not?
Because I asked?
Student:  Well because
on the thing it says abc,
abd, and ace.
Prof: Yes,
but I wonder if you agree.
Maybe he's wrong.
There's precedent for people
being wrong.
Sam?
Student:  Isn't --
abd is the same as
abe.
Prof: Right,
because if you count the other
way, bae is the same as
abd.
Right?
You go two in a row and then
skip one, just go the other way
around.
Okay?
Because it shouldn't make any
difference which way you go
around.
Okay?
Or there would be ace -- right?
-- where you skip every time.
But there's only one way of
doing that.
Okay, so three modifications.
And if you go to four,
five, six, it's the same thing,
except hydrogens are what you
count instead of bromines.
Okay?
So that was consistent with
experimental observation of how
many isomers there were of these
mono-, di-, and tri-substituted
benzenes.
Yes?
Student:  What was he
using to observe these
modifications?
What technique --
Prof: So how would he
know they were different,
that there were three different
substances?
Suppose he had them.
He had to prepare them of
course.
Maybe they were not preparable
-- right?
-- in which case you'd have a
count that was too low.
But how would you know you had
three different things?
How could you tell things were
different?
Yes?
Student:  Boiling point.
Prof: Boiling point;
melting point;
color maybe,
although these aren't colored;
density.
Okay?
Some physical property you have
to measure.
Right?
The analysis obviously is going
to be the same,
because they're isomers.
And of course,
if you're not very good at
measuring things,
you might get a melting point
between two samples that differs
by two degrees.
You guys are experienced in lab.
Does that mean they're
different?
What do you say Wilson?
Your experience is that it
doesn't tell they're different?
Okay.
So it's not trivial.
You have to be a good
experimentalist.
You have to be able to prepare
them and you have to be able to
tell when things are the same
and when they're different.
But if you do,
then you can count isomers.
But you have to bear this in
the back of your mind that you
might be making a mistake
because of your experimental
observations.
Okay, now how about if it were
a triangle, right?
Then if you had a
monobromobenzene,
you could have the bromo either
at a or at b;
although it's conceivable you
couldn't prepare one of them,
or one of them would be
reactive for some reason.
Okay?
And if you had two,
you could have ab,
or ac,
or bd,
or ad.
There'd be four modifications
instead of three,
assuming you could prepare them
all.
Right?
And then you can go on to the
tribromo and see there would be
six.
Okay, so by counting isomers,
you could get information about
the structure.
Okay?
In fact, the paper that I
xeroxed this from had written
in,
in old brown ink,
the letters from the bottom
u,
k, e, k, e, l,
going around the ring,
for a, b, c, d, e, f.
And written next to these
things was names for the
compounds;
elukek and so on;
ekeluk,
ekulek,
for the order of these things.
Do you see what's funny?
Student:  They're
anagrams of Kekulé.
Prof: Right.
No, ekulek,
they said, was Arabic for
hexagon;
that's what was written in the
book.
So you've got humorists in all
ages.
Okay, now let's try applying
the idea of isomer count to see
if we can distinguish,
among Dewar's models of benzene
that I showed you.
So first there's the one top
and center, which is what we
call the Kekulé
structure of benzene;
okay, single bond,
double bond,
single bond,
double bond.
How many isomers?
Okay, how many monosubstituted
isomers, if you put just one
bromine in?
And if that were the structure,
a faithful representation of
the arrangement,
how many different ones could
you get?
Just one.
Okay all the hydrogens are,
in that sense,
equivalent.
Okay, how about if they're di,
how many could you get?
There's one,
two, three, four,
five.
Right?
So are they all different?
Kate, what do you say?
Student:  The purple and
the red are the same -- .
Prof: You say the purple
and the red are the same.
Anything else?
Student:  The two blue
ones.
Prof: The two blues are
the same.
Now does everybody agree with
that?
Sherwin?
Student:  With the
purple you've got the red ones
across a double bond.
Prof: Ah ha!
the red one is across a square,
and the purple one is across
just a single bond.
Right?
So those are different,
if this model is faithful in
that respect.
Okay?
So, but we should take that one
out, because that one goes
across both a square and a
single bond.
<<computer tone
sounds>>
Ah, that's somebody else;
okay.
Okay, now so there'd be four
disubstituted isomers if it were
that, and Kekulé
found three.
Right?
Now how about if it were this
structure?
How many monos?
If you replace just one
hydrogen, how many different
hydrogens?
Elizabeth?
Student:  Six.
Prof: Six.
They're all different.
Right?
So there'll be six monos.
How many di's?
Well let's count them.
So we'll start from the top
left there.
There would be those sets of
di's, the ones connected by
those arrows.
And then we could start from
the top --
pardon me, five of those --
then we could start from that
one and there'd be four,
and three, and two additional
ones,
and one, from that,
that hasn't been counted
before.
So we'd have fifteen
disubstituted isomers.
Right?
Now how about these?
Notice for these two that in
both cases it's AA,
BB, AA.
In the bottom one it's turned
on its side, but the same
relationship,
the symmetry of it.
Right?
Everybody see that?
Okay, so these will have the
same number of isomers,
even though their structures
are obviously different,
but the same number of isomers.
So there'll be two
monosubstituted isomers,
either an A or a B.
And now we've got the di's to
figure out, and it turns out
there'll be six.
I'll let you do that yourself.
Okay, so two six there.
Now how about if it were this,
which is AA,
BB, CC, because it doesn't have
as much symmetry.
The red ones don't have as much
symmetry as the blue ones,
although they're the same as
one another.
So it turns out there are three
monos, A or B or C,
and there are nine di's;
and you can work those out if
you want to.
Okay, so you can't distinguish
among the red ones,
or between the blue ones,
but you can distinguish a black
one from an aqua one,
from a blue, from a red.
Okay, so again you can get
information about structure by
counting isomers,
if you're good enough,
and you can prepare them,
and you can tell them apart.
Okay, now here's a problem for
you to do for Monday,
and you can work in groups if
you want to.
But take -- this is planar and
two-dimensional,
right?
But in truth,
because carbons are
tetrahedral, when they form four
single bonds,
the others are not planar.
Right?
And I've drawn here how each of
them would look in three
dimensions,
with some things,
the wedges, coming out toward
you,
and other things,
the dotted ones,
going back into the page.
Right?
So if you consider these in
three dimensions,
how many isomers can you get?
Right? That's the question.
Mono and disubstituted isomers.
Will you be able to distinguish
these, if they're
three-dimensional?
And -- that one,
remember, is called Dewar
benzene --
and the one that's not included
was prismane or what's called
"Ladenburg"
benzene.
Remember I said we'd talk about
Ladenburg;
he's coming up.
So that's another possibility,
a three-dimensional symmetrical
prism.
Right?
Which obviously Dewar couldn't
make with his models,
because they would -- unless he
distorted them and bent them,
right?
Okay, so the question is,
how many mono- and
disubstituted isomers can you
get from these,
if they're three-dimensional?
So you guys can get together
and talk that over and tell me
on Monday.
Okay?
Now there's another way to get
-- to infer structure,
and that's from synthesis.
So Kekulé, in 1867,
reported that three acetone
molecules,
shown on the left there -- you
see the C double bond O and the
two methyls attached to each
central carbon.
So three of those come together
at a, at b,
at c,
losing water,
and they form the double bonds
on the right.
So if that's the way the stuff
forms, then the three carbons in
this compound called mesitylene
should be on every other carbon
of the ring -- right?
-- because of the way it was
put together by losing waters
between them.
So that's another way of
figuring out where something is,
by synthesis.
Notice incidentally that there
are little dots in the middle of
some of these bonds.
Why do you think those dots are
there?
I think it's because this is a
picture of a real model,
that was made with wire coming
out of balls,
and that was the thing that
screwed them together.
Dewar had sent to
Kekulé,
when he wanted to come work
with him, a set of these
brass-strip models.
So this I think is
Kekulé's version,
from brass-strip models.
Notice the funny bonds between
the carbon and the oxygen,
the double bonds,
those triangles.
Those are made of stiff wire
that comes straight out and then
were fastened together at an
angle.
Okay?
Here's a picture actually of
the model that Kekulé
used in his lectures to show
benzene.
And you can see that the carbon
is tetrahedral.
Okay?
Yes?
Student:  Doesn't the
story go that Kekulé
also had a dream about a snake
eating itself?
Prof: Yeah,
that he made up in 1890.
This is long after this.
It's conceivable that he had
such a dream,
but it was a story told for
amusement.
Okay, so here he is at the time
he did this, in 1865,
in Ghent.
And he was surrounded with some
hotshots.
Koerner, for example,
who was a young man.
He acted as Kekulé's
secretary at this time,
as well as a lab worker,
and suffered from rheumatism.
He came from Central Germany,
which is a very sort of damp
place a lot of the time,
and cloudy, and so it wasn't
good for his rheumatism;
nor was Ghent in Belgium.
So, on his doctor's advice,
he went to sunny Palermo in
Sicily.
So Palermo is down there on the
northwest coast of Sicily.
And Sicily is a very
interesting place in history.
It was liberated in 1860,
just before this time,
after 2700 years of occupation
by successive cultures.
Okay?
And the most recent one was
Garibaldi, who came down with
his Red Shirts in 1860 to free
Sicily from the Bourbons,
from the Spanish crown.
Okay?
And Cannizzaro came along and
established this laboratory in
Palermo.
In 1860, he helped both
Garibaldi, and the late
Avogadro, and Gay-Lussac.
Both of these were
revolutionaries,
although in different senses.
Garibaldi was revolutionary
politically,
and Avogadro was revolutionary
about knowing the atomic weight
and molecular weight of
compounds through gas density.
But in his way,
Cannizzaro was a cautious
person.
This is what he said when he
spoke in London,
in 1872, on chemistry teaching.
He said: "Above all we
should take care that the pupils
do not form to themselves any
mechanical or geometrical
conception of the cause and
effects of the
quantivalence"
(that is, the valence) "of
atoms.
They must frequently be
reminded that chemical facts
neither prove not disprove
anything relating to size,
form, continuity,
distance, relative disposition,
etcetera, etcetera,
of the atoms."
That is, don't use these
arguments for this purpose of
finding where things -- where
atoms are in molecules.
This is just a fancy that will
appeal to students but isn't
anything real.
This was a very cautious,
conservative point of view,
but was shared by all the
leaders in chemistry.
"If we are sometimes
obliged to speak of the relative
position of atoms in the
molecules,
and even to give graphic
representation of these
positions,
we must hasten to remark that
these figures are nothing but
artifices of the mind,
intended to represent to the
sight that which in reality we
perceive only through the veil
of transformations."
(So it's only through reactions
that you try to infer something
about this; it's not something
real.)
"But that we do not really
know what it is that corresponds
to that which we call position,
either in space,
or in the mutual action of
different portions of
matter."
But he was one of the leaders,
right?
The followers,
the students were more --
didn't take this,
right?
So Koerner, who had just come
down,
for his health,
and joined Cannizzaro --
in 1869 he came down,
or he came down in 1866,
I think, or seven -- he wrote a
paper called Facts Serving to
Determine Chemical Position in
Aromatic Substances.
Right?
So a completely different point
of view from what Cannizzaro
advocated three years later --
right?
-- to determine position.
Cannizzaro, to be fair to him,
was saying that you have to be
different in what you teach and
what you do research on.
Teaching should be things you
really know for sure,
and research should be things
where you're trying to push back
the frontier.
But anyhow, Koerner wrote in
this paper, in 1869:
"The dogma of the
impossibility of determining the
atomic constitution of
substances,
which until recently was
advocated with such fervor by
the most able chemists,
is beginning to be abandoned
and forgotten;
and one can predict that the
day is not far in the future
when a sufficient collection of
facts will permit determination
of the internal architecture of
molecules.
A series of experiments
directed toward such a goal is
the object of this paper."
Right?
So that's what he was trying to
do.
If he came along fifty years
later, what would he have used,
to find the position of atoms
in molecules?
X-ray, right?
But he's using only reactions
and counting isomers.
Right?
So only the properties of
things and elemental
composition.
Okay, "facts will permit
determination of the internal
architecture."
So this was a really new idea.
And the paper,
when it was published,
was introduced and warmly
endorsed by Cannizzaro,
who went on to say,
later, that you shouldn't be
teaching this to students,
but it is a good thing to study.
Okay?
So Koerner had -- there's a
thing called the Koerner Proof,
which indeed he proved.
But it's not what he did in
1869.
But this is very interesting.
So you have,
among disubstituted isomers,
you have these possibilities.
Okay?
Now, how could you tell which
is which?
Suppose you had three bottles.
One is black,
one red, one blue,
but they're not colored,
they're just white crystals;
or liquids maybe in this case.
How could you tell which one is
which?
How could you put a label on
the bottle?
Well you could label them just
with names, call them something
like ortho, meta and para,
which doesn't mean anything.
Right?
But how do you know what
structure they have?
Cory?
Student:  Differences in
melting point.
Prof: Oh,
differences in melting point
will show they're different.
But how do you know which one
will have the lowest melting
point?
You have to have some theory
about melting point as a
function of structure;
which didn't exist.
Or do you have such a theory?
Student:  Polarity.
Prof: Polarity.
But notice, to be -- yeah,
one of them would be non-polar.
But people weren't measuring
polarity at this time.
So that was out of the question.
Okay, here's how Koerner did it.
He added a third identical
substituent and counted the
isomers.
So suppose you start with a
black one,
you add a third one,
down to the right,
or down at the bottom,
or -- and that's all,
because if you added down to
the left it would be the same as
down at the bottom,
and if you added over to the
left it would be the same as
down to the --
over to the left would be the
same as down to the right.
Everybody see that?
You can only get two isomers,
starting from there.
If you start from the red one,
you can get either of those.
Can you get anything else,
from the red one?
Andrew?
Student: You get another
one on the left.
Prof: Yeah,
down to the left will be a
different one.
So you'll get three from that
one.
And how about if you start with
the blue one and put a third one
in?
Maria, what do you say?
If you start with the blue one
and put a third blue substituent
in?
Student:  You have the
one in the middle.
Prof: Speak up a little.
Student:  You have the
one in the middle.
Prof: Right,
you can get the one in the
middle.
Student:  And everything
else is just --
Prof: Nothing else.
Right?
Only one possibility there.
Okay?
So one will give one,
one will give two,
one will give three;
supposing that all the
reactions work.
Right?
So it establishes the identity,
not only of the disubstituted,
but only also of the
trisubstituted isomers.
One comes from one of the
original bottles,
one comes from two,
and one comes from three.
So you know it.
Pretty clever.
And these were called -- these
are called now ortho,
meta and para.
But those aren't the names that
Koerner used.
Or more properly,
they are the names that he
used, but not to name the way we
do it now.
If anybody, he had the right to
name them,
but he didn't get it because he
was off in left-field down in
Palermo,
and the people up in Germany,
who were influential,
were the ones that finally
named them.
But notice that this argument
holds if benzene is a hexagon.
But if it were a pentagonal
pyramid, or some other geometric
structure, then this argument
wouldn't work at all.
Right?
So you have first to know that
all the positions are equivalent
in benzene;
that it's not like some of
those Dewar structures we were
just looking at.
So how can you do that?
This was proven,
in this paper in 1869,
by Koerner.
The paper was published in
Palermo,
in the Giornale di Scienze
Naturale ed Economiche di
Palermo,
which is the Journal of
Natural Science and Economics of
Palermo.
It's a beautiful big journal
with big wide margins on the
page and so on.
But it had no circulation
whatever.
People in Germany,
years later,
were still trying to prove
this, what he proved.
Okay, now here's a question.
Are the four valences of carbon
equivalent;
that is, are they all the same
or might one of them be a thick
bond, say, different from the
other three?
Right?
Or, might it even be that two
of the bonds are different;
one's long, or one of them's
curly.
Might all four be different?
Can you think of any evidence
to say that the bonds in methane
are equivalent?
How could you prove this?
Alison, you got any idea?
What technique is Koerner using?
Pardon me?
Student:  To see if the
isomers are --
Prof: Counting isomers.
So what do you expect if you
have four different bonds in
carbon?
Student:  It matters
where you substitute.
Prof: Right.
How many isomers would you get
if there were four different?
Student:  One substitute.
Prof: You could have a
chlorine on the fat bond,
the long bond,
the curly bond or the normal
bond;
there'd be four isomers,
if you could make them all,
and they didn't interconvert.
Right?
So there's only one methyl
chloride.
Nobody's found a second methyl
So does that prove that they're
all equivalent?
Yeah?
Pardon me?
Student:  Not on its
own.
But they can attach more than
one chlorine to all the bonds.
So they know that they all sort
of -- they will work.
Prof: Okay.
That doesn't prove it alone,
because maybe there's only one
that can be substituted.
Right?
That is, of the one -- if it
had the structure on the right,
with four different bonds,
maybe you could make only one
monosubstituted one.
How many disubstituted ones
could you make then?
Student:  The one.
Prof: If the first one
went in one place,
the second one could go any of
three.
So you'd still say get three
disubstituted.
Unless you could only make one
of those.
Then there would only be two.
So it doesn't really prove it,
the way a mathematician would
like things proven,
but it's a plausibility,
at least.
Okay?
But it turns out that -- so the
evidence is there's only one
isomer known,
but it's not really proof.
Now Koerner,
in order to make a real proof,
had to make some assumptions,
and these he stated in 1867,
two years before the paper
we're talking about.
And the first is direct
replacement.
And he wrote:
"If one grants that in
simple transformation the new
substituent assumes the position
of the element
displaced…."
So you can take a substituent
off and put a new one there,
but it will go in the same
place that the old one came off.
Everything doesn't rearrange.
You need that in order to make
arguments like he wants to make.
Right?
And in fact that's often true.
It's certainly logically
parsimonious.
It's the simplest assumption
you can make,
and it usually is true.
But there are rearrangements
that do sometimes occur,
and we'll talk about those
later on.
But anyhow, for his argument
you have to assume direct
replacement.
And the second assumption is
experimental distinguishability,
which we've been talking about.
"Most of the
demonstrations are based on
establishing the identity or
difference of several substances
of the same composition,
but obtained by different
reactions."
So you have to be confident
that you can tell when things
are the same and when they're
different.
We just were talking about that.
But Koerner was in an
especially good position to do
this, because he was really
skilled in the lab.
In fact, he got a Silver Medal
at a Paris exposition,
one of these international
expositions,
for his collection of beautiful
crystals that he had lovingly
prepared,
and they had different shapes
and so on.
That's one way you can tell
things apart.
And, in fact,
this bottle here,
says up at the top -- I don't
think you can read it.
But it says,
Laboratorio di Chimica
Organica,
and it says Acido,
Ac., Salicilico.
So what is it?
Salicylic Acid.
This is Koerner's sample --
right?
-- of salicylic acid.
And here are his beautiful
crystals of
2,6-dinitro-3-bromotoluene.
You can't see them so well here.
Well you can see that they're
still beautiful crystals,
right?
So those are some of his prize
crystals.
And here you can -- so crystals
are the best way to tell.
And there are pictures of those
things that were Koerner's.
Okay, now here's his proof,
based on those assumptions.
Okay, so there are three known
isomers of
hydroxycarboxylbenzene.
So you don't know anything
about the structure.
All you know is you is you have
C_6H_4.
You originally had C_6H_6,
but one of the H's has been
replaced by OH,
and another H by COOH.
And the names of these things
are salicylic acid,
which I just showed you,
hydroxybenzoic acid,
and parahydroxybenzoic acid.
So the names don't mean
anything, but those are just
what the bottles are called.
Right?
Now, you want to use the
existence of at least three.
You don't -- there might be
eighteen, for all you know,
disubstituted ones.
Right?
But you know there are at least
these three, and you can do
experiments with them.
So these are the experiments.
First you treat it with HCl and
heat it up -- this was done by
Graebe in 1866 -- and it loses
the COOH.
Remember, we talked about how
you could take benzoic acid,
take the COOH off and have
benzene.
Here it's done,
take the COOH off,
but you're left with still the
OH.
And that compound,
as we mentioned before,
is called phenol.
Right?
But you can do the same trick
with parahydroxybenzoic acid,
and you get the same phenol,
not a different one.
What does that tell you?
It tells you that the
difference between salicylic
acid and parahydroxybenzoic acid
is not where the OH is.
Right?
They have to have the same
position of the OH because -- or
at least equivalent ones --
because you get the same phenol
out.
And it was found also by Graebe
that you could convert
hydroxybenzoic acid to methyl
anisate -- that's the OH becomes
OCH_3;
and so same for the acid.
And then you can convert it to
anisic acid, taking the CH_3 off
on the acid group;
from the ester, that is to say.
And you can convert phenol by
way of bromoanisole -- Koerner,
I believe, did this -- and then
with sodium and CO_2,
to get the same anisic acid.
Right?
So the OH position has to be
the same in hydroxybenzoic acid
as it was in salicylic and
parahydroxy.
Right?
So the conclusion is the
difference among the three
isomers that are known --
salicylic, hydroxybenzoic acid,
parahydroxybenzoic --
is not where the OH is,
since the O survives in
identical compounds.
So, for example,
it couldn't be like these three
isomers of Dewar's structure
here.
Suppose that were one of the
acids, and that were another
one, and that were the third.
Then when you took the COOH
off, you'd have three different
OH compounds.
Everybody with me?
You see that?
So the difference among these
three,
whatever it is that makes them
different,
can't be where the OH is,
because you can remove the COOH
and they're all the same.
Okay, that's the first step.
And the conclusion is the sites
occupied by OH are either
identical, or equivalent.
Here's what's equivalent.
So suppose they could be this.
There's OH, COOH.
See did I? Yeah here.
So you could have that OH,
that OH and that -- no,
there's;
okay, sorry I'm messing this up.
There's one,
one, one, two,
three.
The OHs in those are not the
same position -- one's the top
right, the other's the top left
-- but they're equivalent,
right?
Once you got it,
you could flop if over and
they're the same as one another.
Okay, so we know at least that
much.
So let's call the OH position,
which is either the same or
exactly equivalent,
call it Ï‰,
just for a name.
So OH is in the position of
HÏ‰;
that we know,
in all three compounds.
Can you guess what you do next?
Next -- yeah?
Student:  Probably take
the OH off and leave the COOH
on.
Prof: Ah!
Take the OH off and leave the
COOH.
Right?
And that's possible too.
You can treat it with
phosphorus pentachloride,
which converts OH to Cl,
and then with sodium and water,
which takes the chlorine off
and leaves hydrogen.
So you get benzoic acid.
And what do you do next?
Do it to one of the other
compounds, right?
There, and you get the same
benzoic acid.
Or you do it here -- and I
think Koerner is the guy who did
that, although I can't --
haven't found a paper to that
effect.
But anyhow, he says that you
get the same benzoic acid.
So what does that prove?
So the COOH positions are not
fundamentally different in the
three compounds.
So the OH positions are
equivalent, and also the COOH
positions are equivalent.
How can they then be different,
the three compounds?
Because they're clearly
different.
It must be their relative
positions that are different.
Okay?
The three isomers do not differ
because of the absolute position
of the COOH.
So the three sites of COOH are
equivalent, and we can name them
x and y and z.
None of them can be exactly the
same,
because if they were exactly
the same then those
hydroxybenzoic acids,
two of them at least,
would've been the same,
if the COOHs -- because we know
the OHs were the same.
Okay?
So, for example,
it could be this way in Dewar's
benzene.
You could have that position
for x, that for y,
that for z.
And they're all different with
respect to Ï‰.
Okay?
The Ï‰'s will all be the
same.
So that would be a possible
structure, according to this.
In this particular case,
Ï‰ would be the same as x,
y and z, as a site for a single
substituent, if it were this
structure.
So Arppe, a chemist,
had made a compound which he
called nitroaniline,
which was benzene that had NH_2
and NO_2 in it,
and it was known by
transformations,
that the NH_2 was Ï‰,
that position OHÏ‰,
and the NO_2_ was in
y;
that is, you could interconvert
groups and make it into one of
those known hydroxybenzoic
acids.
So you knew it was Ï‰
and y.
Okay?
Now, you do a transfer -- and
it's related to that particular
hydroxybenzoic acid.
Okay?
Now, you replace the NH_2 by Br
-- and we'll talk about these
next semester,
what particular reactions did
that --
and then you change NO_2 to
NH_2, and then you replace the
NH_2 by chlorine.
So now you've got benzene with
bromine;
that must be in the Ï‰
position, because it replaced
the first NH_2.
And then chlorine is in y
because it substituted for the
second NH_2, which came from the
NO_2, which was in y.
Okay?
So it's Ï‰ and y.
Can you see what he's going to
do next?
He replaces the NH_2 by Cl,
and then changes NO_2 to NH_2,
and then replaces it by Br.
Why?
So now he's prepared a compound
which clearly has chlorine in
the position Ï‰
and bromine in position y.
I see pursing of brows and so
on.
Is everybody clear?
So he's prepared two -- from
the same compound he's prepared
a bromide chloride.
Right?
One of them is Ï‰
bromide y chloride,
and the other has them
exchanged.
And what do you think he
observed?
They're the same.
What does that show?
Student:
>.
Prof: It shows that
Ï‰ is the same as y,
because otherwise these would
be different when you put
different atoms in them;
assuming you have the
experimental technique to tell
when things are different.
Okay?
So now -- so it couldn't be,
for example,
a pentagonal pyramid,
which one had bromine in y,
and the other had chlorine --
chlorine in y,
the other had chlorine and
Ï‰ and bromine in y.
It couldn't be that,
those would be different.
Okay?
So there must be at least four
equivalent substituted
positions: Ï‰,
y, x and z.
Okay?
And that would be consistent
with that structure we showed
before, this one.
So it could be that.
It doesn't have to be a hexagon.
Now, here's the next step.
So you start with a compound
that's known to be in the meta
series.
It's got OH in Ï‰,
and nitro, NO_2 -- he wrote
AzO_2 -- in x.
And you have another one that
has again OH in the position
Ï‰, but bromine in x,
instead of nitro.
And now you start doing
substitutions.
Remember, he used
"meta"
differently from the way we do.
Okay, so first he put in a
bromine someplace,
and then a nitro someplace,
and got
bromonitrometanitrophenol.
Okay, he added a bromo and a
nitro group.
So you know that's the benzene
core, with H_2,
with a nitro someplace,
with a bromo someplace.
Those are the ones you just put
in.
But the others are still where
they were.
OH is in Ï‰
and nitro is in x position.
And now you go to the other
compound and put in two nitro
groups.
So you don't know where those
two nitro groups are,
but you know Ï‰
's -- that OH is in Ï‰
and bromine is in x.
Everybody see what you've done
now?
And you know what he observed?
Those two compounds are
identical.
Can you see what conclusion you
get from that?
These are identical, right?
But one of them has bromine in
x, and the other has nitro in x.
How can they be identical?
There must be a second x
position that's -- there must be
two positions that are
equivalent, right?
Now, could any of those
positions be ones we already
know?
Could it be Ï‰?
We already know Ï‰,
x, y and z are the same,
right?
Could this new x be one of
those?
Could it be Ï‰?
No, because we already got
Ï‰, so it can't be Ï‰.
Could it be y or z?
No, because those would've
started from a different
compound in the first place,
if it were y or z.
Right?
You know that this is in x.
It's not y, not z.
Right?
So there must be a second x,
right?
We'll call it x'.
There must be two positions,
x and x'.
They're not equivalent to x,
or y.
They're not the same as x or y
or z or Ï‰.
It's a new one.
Okay?
So that's what they are.
So there must be at least five
equivalent positions.
Now that would be consistent
with that pentagonal pyramid,
right?
All the five around the base of
it are at five equivalent
positions.
But you can't get three
different disubstituted ones
among those positions.
Right? So it couldn't be that.
So none of Dewar's models work
with this, although the perfect
hexagon will work;
a perfect one,
not alternating single and
double bonds.
And the equilateral triangular
prism, the Ladenburg benzene
will also work.
So as I said,
it would work with either of
those, except that the one on
the right doesn't give the right
number of disubstituted isomers.
Now Koerner's own argument,
that the sixth position is
equivalent,
was faulty, because it hinged,
in a subtle way,
on assuming that the benzene
was hexagonal before you proved
it was.
It wasn't obvious,
but it's true if you look at it
carefully.
But it is possible,
using group theory,
to construct a logically
rigorous argument on the basis
of his evidence.
His last step of his argument
was wrong but his evidence was
adequate to prove it.
So he was right in his
intuition that this proved it,
and he was right in his
conclusion that all the
positions are equivalent.
So he deserves enormous credit
for formulating the logic of the
first true structural proof;
not just one of these
plausibility things,
like there's only one
monosubstituted methane --
chloromethane,
therefore all the positions are
equivalent.
Right? That's just plausibility.
But this is a real rigorous
proof.
Now how many isomers do you
think there are of C_2H_4Br_2?
Think about it.
Ethane with two bromines,
how many isomers?
Student:  Two.
Prof: Pardon me?
Somebody guess.
Student:  Two.
Prof: John?
Student:  Three.
Prof: And how would you
get three?
Student:  Because
there's a double bond on the --
Prof: No double bond.
There's six things on it.
So forget that one.
Prof: Yeah.
If it were a double bond you'd
be right.
But there are no double bonds.
Corey?
Student:  Two.
Prof: And what would you
call them?
How would you distinguish them,
or describe them?
Student:  One would have
one bromine on each carbon and
one would have two bromines on
one carbon.
Prof: Good.
So you could have two bromines
on one carbon or one bromine on
each carbon.
So there should be two isomers.
Now, in that same journal,
the same volume of the same
journal,
in 1869, in Palermo,
a guy named Paternó
said the three isomers of
dibromoethane,
supposing they actually exist,
can easily be explained without
assuming any difference among
the four valences of carbon.
You don't need curly bonds,
long bonds and stuff like that.
And here's how he explained it,
with this picture.
Right?
So both, on the leftmost they
have two on the same atom.
The other two have one on each
atom.
And how are they different --
one on each carbon atom -- but
how do they differ?
In the phase of rotation,
around the carbon-carbon single
bond.
Right?
And at the bottom he says -- or
actually notice there's a little
black thing in the middle.
What do you think it is?
Dana, what do you think?
Student:  Some way to
join the --
Prof: Right,
it's a case of rubber tubing.
Because this is an artist's
picture of an actual model made
out of sticks and balls.
Right?
And sure, those things aren't
super-imposable.
Right?
But he says at the bottom:
"It is superfluous to say
that this is only a way of
representing the facts,
and that all these ideas need
to be tested
experimentally."
So we'll see next time what
kind of reception this received.